ok si je pouvais vous aider je le ferai
mais je sais pas quoi faire je sais pas
voyager dans le temps j'ai une idée on
tourne une vidéo on explique à la cyber
historienne ce qu'on pense de ces
méthodes
on lui donne un titre put à cliquer pour
la rendre virale est comme ça dans deux
siècles alors a tellement circuler que
tout le monde va connaître et que la
cyber historienne la verra je peux me
permettre ce complètement où tu peux te
le permettre
d'accord alors j'attends vos idées si on
avait commencé par soumettre l'agent
ordalie l'aurait pas filer c'est pas le
problème mais il a de fortes chances
pour que lui ou un autre reviennent pour
finir le travail
et là on shoppe on lui prend sa machine
à voyager dans le temps et on y va c'est
encore moi me torturer pas s'il vous
plaît je reviens de la part de votre
super historienne elle va vous
rencontrer
[Musique]
autrefois alliés d'or qui connaissent et
guay ma prof montre si mes récents
viennent de me recevoir
bonne chance et cela par votre appareil
à manger dans temps je me dis c'est pas
mal comme entre même époque
pour nous vous êtes une ancêtre comme
celles que vous avez ramené avec vous
vous en servez déjà beaucoup trop
historiens que ses potes sont
incroyablement se trouvait ça suffit à
faire de moi une menace ça ça sera votre
vaisseau dans des sites us entrée elle
vous attend
bonjour ancêtres numéro 9
vous m'avez posé une montagne de
problèmes à récupérer les ancêtres que
je compte interroger jalouse pas
vraiment quand je vois le lot dont vous
avez hérité me reste juste à décider
comment mettre fin à cette anomalie y
mettre fin
je pensais plutôt vous voudriez savoir
comment en tirer profit
la question ne se pose pas vous ancêtres
sont corrompus ce sont des anachronismes
maintenant et lorsque des anachronismes
se présente ou les éliminant pourquoi
croyez vous que nous les avons laissés
venir ici à la moindre occasion aux
barres je me passe qui se passe on pour
essayer de leur voulait une de leurs
machines
si tu m'aides je connais une taverne à
saint domingue
tu es le meilleur homme de la terre
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mais ensuite nous
rentrerons à mon époque et je te montre
ce qu'est la vraie gastronomie mais
godefroy qu'est ce que vous faites ici
je rentrais de la forêt où je vous ai
croisé est une dame très bizarre est
venu m'aborder pour me demander de lui
parler de ma vie dont le futur vous
rendez compte
oui puisqu'on est ici aussi mais de la
famille mais ça vous prend souvent
cuivre des maraudes au milieu des bois
elle m'a promis que c'était pas de la
sorcellerie
et puis elle vous ressemble c'est ça
c'est bien ce que je pensais vous n'êtes
pas en mai non mais comment ça elle me
ressemble et y avait un air de famille
à part les cheveux et l'habillement que
je trouve un peu étrange mais c'est pas
possible on n'est pas par an on peut pas
avoir la même descendante
j'ai compris vous êtes fan barré mais
elles font mal à personne au 21ème
siècle
j'ai à peine si lucrecia sort de son
canapé d'habitude par contre je pourrais
vous être utile je vous écoute si j'ai
bien compris vous vous basez sur la
mémoire de vos ancêtres pour écrire
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est ça ça
n'est pas une méthode très rigoureuse
donc leur mémoire peut être corrompue
incomplète manipulés par leurs émotions
par les questions que vous leur posez
tous les bons historiens vous diront
qu'on ne peut pas se baser uniquement
sur la mémoire pour réécrire l'histoire
alors pardon mais permettez moi de
douter de vos compétences parce que vous
avez une éruption pourquoi ne pas
utiliser votre machine pour voyager dans
le temps à les explorer les musées les
archives je ne sais pas exactement quand
elles sont vouées à disparaître c'est
pas moi qui viens du 23ème siècle
mais à mon époque on a encore pas mal de
documents exploitables nos capacités
sont limitées
nous ne pouvons voyager que verano
ancêtres grâce à la reconnaissance adn
et pour un temps très court
c'est pour ça que nous avons eu autant
de mal à retrouver les pirates la
romaine et la glaise heureusement
qu'elle vous entend pas pourquoi ne pas
être passé par mois alors je historienne
je ne m'intéresse pas vraiment au 21ème
siècle
et si je veux travailler sur l'histoire
ancienne je travaille sur l'histoire
ancienne c'est clair ça enfin si j'avais
eu toutes les anomalies vous que vous
auriez vous auriez fond c'est parce que
vous avez maintenant la possibilité
d'accéder aux connaissances historiques
du 21e siècle à travers moi
pardon tant que vous épargner les trois
folles que je me coltine bien sûr et les
autres s'il y en a d'autres à travers
moi vous pouvez accéder aux livres
d'histoire aux archives
tout ce que vous voulez je vous ai dit
on a encore pas mal de documents à mon
époque
si on sait les exploiter je peux même
vous compilez tout ça en vidéo jeux ça
tout le temps et vos ancêtres je suis on
sait en faire quoi dans cette histoire
mais attendez si la prof emma
descendante est la vôtre aussi
alors qu'on n'est pas de la même famille
ça veut dire que je suis non lucrecia
shore champions c'est plus que le sien
et avant siècle ulissi j'imagine que les
renvoyer à leur époque est hors de
question en effet je préfère qu'un
double de mes ancêtres apparaissent
tranquillement pour prendre le relais
plutôt qu'une romane qui débarquerait en
plein vitesse avec un smartphone
pourtant dans dr où la plupart du temps
ça passe
j'adore les 30e docteur mais on est dans
la réalité ici elles peuvent soit
retournée avec vous à votre époque qui
est de toute façon assez déglingué pour
que personne ne les prennent au sérieux
soit rester ici on se débrouillait pour
leur trouver de la place même si je ne
tiens pas à croiser mes ancêtres à
longueur de journée on s'y fait très
vite j'ai du mal à le croire
enfin il me semble que nous avons un
accord allons leur annoncer la nouvelle
aliénor c'est elle qui est censé être
mon sosie
qu'est ce que vous faites hors de votre
salle vous cherchez des toilettes je ne
sais pas trouvé
on reste encore longtemps justement
c'est ça qu'on doit parler on y va nous
sommes parvenus à un accord
vous ne serez plus poursuit et en
échange des changes ne vous concerne pas
c'est entre elle et moi ça veut dire
qu'on peut rentrer chez nous non par
contre on ne peut pas se le permettre
vous pouvez soit repartir avec votre
descendante au 21e siècle et vivre votre
vie soit rester ici lyon vous fera une
place bien que l'idée de vous côtoyez ne
m'enchante pas plus que ça moi non plus
mais ça veut dire que tu as l'élan
elle va rester ici et moi non en fait le
système est plutôt bien pensé il y aura
une année noire ici et une autre au 15e
siècle
donc en fait ça me change pas le cours
de l'histoire sinon t'es qui deux alliés
d'or datant d il a pu rien à face à tant
de ses trains
thierry ramener le vent qui entache
trouve oui alors maison c'est trop xvème
siècle c'était un peu disent ça ira très
influent visera du pays allez hop mais
se fait plus venise à cette époque mais
je le reverrai plus jamais dis toi que
lui te reverra à 6,7 soulage bien que
l'idée que mon fiancé épouser une autre
lucrecia ne m'enchante guère à sa place
ça m'enchanterait pas non plus bon à
vous de choisir
vous partez ou vous restez j'avais des
vaisseaux spatiaux
oui on va dans l'espace les moyens que j
ai aussi qu'il y passe pas oui mais vous
attendez pas à des sous dans
l'hyperespace ou des conneries du genre
ça c'est parce que je n'ai pas encore là
j'en suis la chose
ce serait la première pirates de
l'espace
je rentre 21e siècle c'était boxing
n'est vraiment pas pour moi la gueuse tu
viens ouais l'antiquité parfait thierry
vous pouvez et n'oubliez pas votre part
du marché
je reviendrai vite vous voir je
n'oublierai pas
réd
n'oublie pas non plus la pirate
[Musique]
attendez je veux pas partie quel choc
batterie
[Musique]
ce bordel ces belges je crois qu'on a ce
petit parti en vacances il n'a plus de
tout chez lui en gsm et le froid
perturbe mon appareil jeu mais c'est pas
correct de merde
[Musique]
vous